This episode of DNews is brought to you by
Subaru.
I'm pretty tall, a six-two or so, but there
are people who are smaller…
Amy for instance… but there are also HUGE
in comparison.
Just HOW BIG can we get?
Height is a big deal.
It affects every aspect of a person's life
from their own perception of the world to
how they're perceived.
It's a pretty common misconception that people
were shorter back in the day, but it's simply
not true.
1,000 years ago people were as tall as we
are today, but during the 17th or 18th century,
nutritional deficits during youth caused humans
to shrink 2 and a half inches on average.
Dietary hardship, climate, and disease throughout
history all affect height.
People were NOT shorter in the past, but had
the potential to be as tall as we are now;
though, humans do seem to have some kind of
unofficial upper limit.
The tallest known person in history was Robert
Wadlow.
He stood 8 feet 11.1 inches (2.72M) and was
almost 200 kilos when he died at 22 in 1940.
The man was massive.
The current "world's tallest man," is Sultan
Kösen from Turkey, and he has the same disorder
as Wadlow, a tumor on his pituitary that causes
it to squirt human growth hormone into his
body; increasing his height abnormally.
The reason we don't just keep getting larger
is, we have to live in the world.
Gravity is constantly pulling us down, requiring
our bodies to create bones which counteract
that force.
It's all about balance.
We're reaching the upper limit for human height
because more weight requires larger bones,
which requires more bodily resources to maintain.
As an animal grows, its support structure
must grow with it; which means bones and muscles
must thicken; which can only happen so much.
Plus, seven to eight percent of your body
weight is blood, so if you weigh 200 kilos,
like Wadlow, you'd have 14 kilograms of blood.
That blood needs to be pressurized, and pumped,
which as size increases, it gets more difficult
for the heart; so it needs MORE muscle, and
there's only so much room in the human body.
Elephants and giraffes have highly pressurized
circulatory systems, to keep their blood flowing!
Whales can grow larger than us because they
don't live on land!
The buoyancy of the water around them helps
support their weight; while their bones give
structure to their body.
Air buoyancy is extremely low, only about
zero point one two percent of your weight
at sea level, where the air is thickest.
If our air was thicker, it would help hold
us up, allowing us to grow larger, but it
would have to be a LOT thicker, which could
affect our ability to breathe it in at all.
In space astronauts gain a little height,
growing as much a 3 percent taller because
the fluid in between the vertebrae relaxes
and expands when not under the load of gravity.
For someone like me that could mean adding
another 2 or more inches.
On Mars, where gravity is only 38 percent
of Earth, you'd also get taller.
But if children were sent to Mars, they'd
get big, but Earth gravity would be a struggle
of real proportions.
So they'd kind of be stuck.
If we lived under the water could we grow
larger due to the buoyancy?
Maybe?
But we couldn't walk on land at all because
our bones would break due to the lack of support.
This is also why insects are limited in size;
exoskeletons can only grow so large before
they're too heavy to support themselves!
If you could be a giant safely, would you
want to be?
What's
your ideal height?